Speaker 1: I want to talk about
postmodernism a little bit with you guys.
One of the I am going to suggest to you today
that the. Often misunderstood postmodernism
that the right assigns to the American Left is
actually something that we can correctly ascribe
to the right, and I'm going to give you some
examples here. Now, let's back up a little bit.
One of the criticisms that the right loves to make
about the left is the left's woke postmodernism
means anything goes. Everybody's opinions are
equally valid. Everybody deserves an equal seat
at any table. We must listen, they say. The Left
says we must listen to any harebrained crazy idea,
no matter how unsubstantiated or un backed up,
not backed up it is by empiricism and data or
whatever. And that's how the left gets into these
crazy things that they end up getting into. Like,
you know, all the different things they talk about
and some of the things we've talked about, right,
like Jewish women aren't intersectional enough to
lead the Women's March or whatever the case may
be. Now does that exist on the left to some
degree? Well, yeah, it's a very, very small
thing on the left. But I would argue that this
is a much bigger deal on the right where when
the right says you really can't trust the media
and some guy with a mike on Real America's Voice
is at least potentially just as trustworthy as
actual investigative journalism that is doing
real investigative journalism. Or, for example,
scientists, specialists, public health experts.
They don't necessarily know what's going on.
Some preacher offering you drinkable silver or
some dude on the internet who's vaporizing
hydrogen peroxide. All of these things are equally
likely to be the proper way to deal with
COVID or my sisters. Step mom's brothers,
aunts adopted babysitter is just as
good of a resource on vaccines. As
a doctor that is actually the place where you see
this. Anything goes as long as it's convenient
type of stuff. And look at this example here
is now. You might have been unaware that the
trucker convoy is kind of like still, I guess,
going on, and some Republicans have invited the
truckers to meet with them. And here is video
of a convoy truck, Lee, a trucker convoy leader,
saying to Republican Congressman Jim Jordan.
Listen, the truckers know what's going on with
COVID. COVID is over and truckers are the new
scientist and Jim Jordan loves it. This is the
very caricature of anything goes postmodernism
that they ascribe to the left. Look at this.
Speaker 7: So, yeah, the country's figured it
all out, and they appreciate the fact that you're
you're standing up and saying first of any, I
mean, the child becomes a scientist for America
and the world, and there's no science across the
world and easily tested that supports any of the
mandates or the underlying emergency declarations.
There's no date or science. COVID is not
an American. People understand this war crime
was our off. Governments need to be bold and
grab a war crime and take this exit strategy sadly
enough to teeth the Trump up to now stand up as
a scientists write the truckers.
Speaker 1: This country is going
down the tubes, but truckers doing the work
of scientists are what is going to save us.
This is the very it's a caricature of
the very postmodernism that they claim to
oppose. There's other examples of this.
Bryce Mitchell, the UFC fighter Last week,
I played a clip of Bryce Mitchell saying, I
don't know what's going on in Russia and Ukraine
and then giving 10 unsubstantiated
opinions and conspiracy theories.
And Tucker Carlson brings him on as someone to
be listened to. Remember this? This is the same
thing, guys. Everybody gets an equal seat at
the table. UFC fighter trucker on matters of
geopolitics and epidemiology. Why the hell not?
Speaker 2: Honored to have Bryce Mitchell
join us tonight, Bryce. Thanks so much
for coming on and for what you said.
I haven't seen anybody express it better
than you did. Why did you say that?
Well, thank you so much for having me, brother,
and I said that because that's the first thing
that I thought when he asked me and I was trying
to give him the best answer that I could, and
that's just my genuine thoughts on the subject.
How do you get to be so honest when everyone,
everyone else is afraid to say what
they think and you just kind of say it?
Well, I don't have to be worried about being
fired from my job for saying what I want to
say. There's a lot of people out there that
do agree with me, but they can't say things
that I get to say, even though they think I'm OK.
Speaker 1: Anyway, his explanation for how he's
coming up with all this stuff doesn't really
matter. But again, they say the left has this
anything goes sort of idea, but it is they who
are actually doing exactly that. And then lastly,
Madison Cawthorn and again, God knows absolutely
nothing about foreign policy or anything.
And it has worked on the right. Here is a
guy at one of his town halls actually saying,
Can you explain Russia and Ukraine to me? Yeah.
Speaker 8: Anybody else? Yeah. How are you,
sir? We had this mess in the Eastern Europe there
with Ukraine. I know you've made some reference to
President Zelensky being involved or being in the
government being corrupt. We're all I think we're
all trying to figure this thing out. I mean,
it seems like we're on the precipice of what
could be a possible major disaster. Can
you clarify some of that for us so we
know where we stand with it? I will.
Speaker 1: So one and again, we already
looked at Madison Cawthorn answer. It's whacked.
It's outrageously critical of Zelensky. It attacks
Ukraine and does all these different things
doesn't matter. The specifics don't matter.
But the point is, the right loves to ascribe this
exact type of listen, this person's an expert or
whatever. Maybe we. Why do you? Why is a blue
haired feminist explaining gender when that's
not really? You need a doctor, I guess, to explain
sex and gender or whatever. But then they've got
Madison Cawthorn explaining geopolitics. They've
got Bryce Mitchell, UFC fighter explaining foreign
relations, and they've got the truckers acting as
scientists. It's absurd, and we can't allow them
to get away with accusing the left of doing
exactly what it is that they do every single day.